it's time for drew's news where we toast
to life with our good news goblets or
shallots whatever you like click click
um and with me at the desk is my trusty
news muse russ u.s matthews clean clean
hi everybody
all right if you're a die-hard for dirty
dancing well it is time to pack your
bags oh my god by the way anyone
remember kellerman's in the movie of
course hello well travel and leisure
reports that you can now stay
in the same resort where johnny and baby
fell in love
me up true that's right
the movie's set at the kellerman's
institute in the catskills but the real
resort is in the blue ridge mountains of
virginia and all spring and summer you
can go on a dirty dancing weekend
complete with a movie themed scavenger
hunt and dance lessons and maybe someone
will like throw you up in the air and
hold you there yes please um ross do you
have hungry eyes for this oh yeah you
did
ah
thank you
i remember it was like one of the first
movies my mom goes i'm not gonna let you
watch that till i watch it
and then she was like do you want to
watch it with me because it was it was
so good i remember i carried a
watermelon oh and she's so mad at
herself too she's like
i know that's what i said i my girls saw
it and
i was like and we're going to take a
break on that one for a little while
where did where did you take the break
like where were you like oh well maybe
after it was finished unfortunately but
i was like let me just take this dvd and
stick it in for you know a few years
from now do you think we could ever do
the big move where you're you know and
by we do the big move i mean you lift me
in the air yeah justin kurtz executive
producer please just
pick me up let me do it
i wish
that i was the emma stone to your ryan
gosling and we could you know reenact it
um but i am not emma stone well if
you're patrick swayze i could be your
jennifer gay
nobody puts rocky in the corner nobody's
with russia
ever all right next up we have a wedding
etiquette question this one really got
me steamed okay pulling off a wedding in
the time of covid is nothing short of a
miracle and i know because i'm trying to
do it right now i'm planning and wow's
up well one writer at insider says
extreme times call for extreme measures
listen to this she admits that for her
wedding she went against all sorts of
decorum and invited b-list guests to her
wedding last minute over text she said
so the people that didn't make the
original cut when she had more room she
was like okay b-list you want to come
all right she said she doesn't regret it
uh the more the merrier i just okay
ready
be list guess how
dare you
listen if i didn't make the cot in the
first round have a nice wedding and by
the way have a nice life
thank you so much
b-list apparently she tried to do it in
a really nice way like explaining like
you know i there was times where i
wasn't able to invite you and then there
was and then i've got seats to fill i
don't know but the whole thing is a no
thank you for me right i just was like
it's not a seat filler event it's your
wedding thank you
exactly get what you get in the time
i i
i i was confused and if i received that
text i would literally send back the
middle finger emoji
i knew why
yeah can you imagine listen it's not
personal to this person i just and no
thank you
[Music]